during one of the movie's pivotal races
Yan attempts to get ahead of the
competition but in the process he loses
control of his vehicle which careens
into a crowd of Spectators Jan is told
it was a freak accident and wasn't his
fault but in the hospital it's revealed
the Collision resulted in a person's
death in the movie trainer Jack Salter
pushes Yan to get back behind the wheel
in time for the 24 Hours of Le Mans to
prove he has what it takes to race
alongside the best
most people can't
I got a feeling you're not most people
through sheer determination and will Yan
manages to place third he overcomes
adversity and kicks off an incredible
racing career the only problem is that
things didn't happen in that order in
real life Martin Burroughs accident took
place in 2015 the 24 Hours of Le Mans
race where Yan triumphantly came in
third occurred in 2013 a full two years
before the crash the movie Alters the
timeline of events so that Yan could
have his lowest moment come before he
took the podium